il ya une petite dizaine d'années il y
avait encore deux médecins sur le canton
c'est ce qui vous est arrivé est
aujourd'hui page empire est tout seul
n'est pas immortel nous pouvons
envisager le futur faut vous habiller
plus simplement quand je vais en vouloir
je suis en retard c'est pas les
comprimés qui vont vous dit rien moi je
la connais personne qui va vous sortir
de l'homme
merci de terrain j'enlève le bas non non
non tu dois arrêter de travailler si tu
veux avoir une chance de guérir que tu
te fasses remplacer
vous avez déjà pratiqué le conflit fait
j'ai une arme à l'internât je sais que
les études de médecine sont donc
malandra krumbholz et beaucoup redoubler
je suis les visées par l'entrée de les
consultations non rendent hommage terme
à cette heure ci voulaient venir avec
moi ça d'accord vous allez y aller tout
seul
je préférerais le docteur
si la wii ware qui s'avère au [ __ ]
aller
merde
chrome médecins aux montres étaient mal
médecin de campagne ça se répondent pas
c'est quoi ces canards ils ont ils ont
lu matic et ça c'est pas des canards
c'est déjà pour les humilier formé à
choper par le cou et puis leur mettre la
bague dans le cul c'est risqué mais ça
vaut le coup que c'est bon j'ai compris
quoi